so so the waiter makes a beautiful
thesis that calls the knife is it's huge
it's six volumes and it's on it's called
the add class of evasion creo so it's
online so I'd be happy to share the
reference with you
I mean I shouldn't only it's it has Maps
because as recordings can actually go
and listen to the various dialects of
evasion Creole and what what people have
found striking is the fact that in terms
of variation it's quite restricted so
anyway you are in hate you can speak to
someone who speaks Creole you speak
Creole so there'll be some words that
are kind of Shibboleth of certain
regions but overall there is no issue
with mutual understanding you know
Asians understand each other when they
speak Creole even though at first I
might be a bit of a station if you come
from different regions and in that atlas
actually taught me that very well that
you have lots of lexical idiosyncrasies
across regions but but the grammar
itself is pretty much similar which one
might say is surprising even that she
had all these influx of Africans from
various language groups right will
expect more variation but but I was so
lucky that the fact that you look at the
hits of Haiti the country was for for a
long time pretty isolated
right after independence it's like
that's something that we can talk about
later the the European forces and the
American forces even though Haiti helped
the u.s. in terms of its independence
getting more territory like I don't know
you've heard about the region approaches
which was create calls because of
Napoleon losing 80 because of the
involution but yet the u.s. quarantine
Haiti very quickly why because it was an
example of of black liberty which was a
threat to the world order back back then
so he was was unthinkable and
unacceptable so it had to be embargoed
and that embargo
people have argued is what actually
created this isolation that in turn gave
fish and Creole it's pretty much its
uniformity because it was little traffic
from outside to heat if
long time he was pretty much self
contained and that helped the language
jail as if you know pretty uniform
system well over time the date I thought
so it will have enough data to document
that weather over time there was more or
less variation because what we have is
purified fragmentary we will have lots
of evidence about you know say
eighteenth-century
Asian Creole we have some archival data
but not enough to be able to compare
what happened in different regions of
the country but what we do have say
going to do 17 eighteenth-century
no strikers has pretty similar you know
to the to the Haitian spoken now so they
were French scholars were writing down
what they would hear they were writing
down you know varieties of Haitian
Creole from the H 19th century and I can
still read those texts no of course you
are written with French orthography and
maybe that's a that's another confound
you know they were probably imposing
their French onto onto the Creole that
were transcribing but if you read that
Creole back then the structures were
pretty similar to the Creole of today
which also is fracking as compared to
English which which has evolved much
faster